you
[Music]
so this is joint work with Michael
Sumner and who is regrettably not
hearing a general sin was was here
sitting in the fourth row and I'm pretty
confident I think I can promise you that
there will be the only talk in this
session without moving images yes so I
talked about here about simple features
and sort of I couldn't find a better
summary then this lovely graph that this
lovely illustration that Allison Horst
posted on Twitter recently simple
features basically makes handling
feature data so that's points lines
polygons data easier a spatial data
easier in our because it's kind of glues
stuff on as an additional column or in
your table in your data frame or table
and keeps them there and then you can do
all your regular many relations with
that in addition you can do all kind of
spatial operations like spatial joins
and operating on the on the geometries
so that was sort of caught up very well
that is the good news so there's a
strong uptake of simplified package by
both users and developers and we
improved by that the interoperability
with spatial databases to you Jason and
also of corn and reference system
handling in in are also special indexes
are computed in fly for instance by as
the intersect and we have now also a
plot support in ggplot2
that takes care of reprojected
incompatible layers there is an
additional thing that is that we added
to that we added to the simple feature
package and that is the issue like it is
very easy to find out where a point lies
inside a polygon or now that's it's a
simple geometry problem but then if you
work with properties like you saw here
we in this graph that we work with
geometries and properties of these
geometries it's not so easy to assess
when you query a point in a polygon to
assess whether what a value would be so
if you have on the left hand
right prints in a land-use map you could
reasonably say that at a particular
point in that polygon the land-use will
be forest but if you have a population
density map which is also a polygon with
a value you cannot say that because the
population density is it's an aggregate
property over the entire polygon so we
made categories for that and that
information is propagated and if you
don't know or if you are on the
right-hand side of the figure you get
warnings when you query these points
that you basically make assumptions that
are not sort of supported by the data so
this is a very nice it starts getting
sort of sort of challenging more
challenging when you have time dependent
data so here we have the classical North
Caroline as sudden infant death data set
where we have two rounds of of
measurements in 74 and 79 this is one of
the firsts published spatial statistics
datasets and we can sort of plot them
and then basically we happen in two as
two columns in the data set and we need
to use gather here to to stack them into
a single column and then we have to
replicate all the geometries and we can
do that but then what happens if you
have like 50 instances of time or when
you have 500 or 5000 you would have like
5000 columns and you were going to stack
all of them and so on it's getting very
messy and also keeping time and columns
is not a good idea at all because where
do you put the timestamp so that you
would have to put it in a column name so
time is an issue there we have time
dependent data where do we do we put it
over multiple columns or do we recycle
features if we put it in a long in a
tidy table that is all not not sort of
not ideal tgd plotting is from something
of an issue there is also a sort of
recurring question of the support for
raster data and it's followed vector and
raster integration this is something you
can Amir emulate by sort of you know
having points on the roster or little
square polygons but it is not going to
bring you far in a sense of scaling why
raster data for those not involved in in
the raster world well very variables
they vary continuously over space or
over
I'm are typically represented more
naturally by regular sampling so think
images do that still images or video but
also also Earth Observation data so
satellite data we have now visible
satellites that give information about
land about ocean about temperature radar
satellites we have satellites that
measure atmospheric composition and
these all come down come down freely now
Europe is here clearly on the ball at
the moment in the Copernicus program and
we have like little less than 10
satellites no running it comes down with
150 terabytes per day so that's that's
quite a sort of that's quite abundant
with sort of the data sets that you can
that you can have access to also climate
data a climate model data is also free
and large decline the coupled model
intercomparison program will generate
sort of over a couple of years around
six which generate fifteen to thirty
petabytes that's a data center I imagine
in early numerous other sources of rusta
data that that are of interest and that
is also what really motivates me that
there is so incredibly much free
information that is collected or
generated that you could that you could
get access to and and use if you could
use it right but it is so hard to do it
quite often so here's an example of an
image that comes from The Sentinel 5p
that we're six months of data were sort
of thrown together and this looks like
what you typically see from models but
this is actually measurement this is
measured atmospheric composition so this
is six months of imagery compiled
together and you see sort of for those
living in Europe you see fairly familiar
pattern but where for instance also see
is the is this see is the the ship lines
flowing here so you see even the no.2
emitted by the bye-bye sea traffic and
it is quite revolutionary that you get
this from pure measurements this of
course a lot of heavy processing going
on there another thing to sort of the
way out to handle time properly and to
deal with raster data and to deal with
more complicated data
in my eyes was dead of data cubes data
cubes the idea of data cubes go back to
OLAP cubes which is sort of there's a
paper from Jim Gray and it's mentioned
on Wikipedia from 1996 so that where
values basically are given for each
combination of dimensions for dimension
values so we can have sales by products
store and week so for every combination
of product of store and week we get a
sales figure we can have population by
gender age plus region in sentences
around we can have temperature by XYZ
and time for dimensional data cube we
can have screen pixels here like which a
two-dimensional or which vary and then
it's three-dimensional like video we can
have also forecasts so like weather
forecasts by time of forecast and time
to forecast so we have two dimensions of
time covering time and that sort of
varies done by variable by XY and
altitude why not handle them entirely as
tidy as long tables as ero would would
suggest in an init Sybil
well there is storage to speed and
indexes right I'm sort of welcome anyone
to put a video stream into an sort of X
Y at time red green blue data set you
don't do that so you could do it but
it's it's sort of it's not going to it's
not going to scale up really much yeah
only for smaller subsets then so what we
do is basically working with arrays
right and arrays are the array has long
history of support in base and also in
deep liar so basically is a very strong
structure that has dim names and dim
names are pretty limited because their
characters are if you want to put time
in dim names then you have to encode it
as character in it's messy but the good
thing is that you can use apply so that
means you can sort of cut out you can
aggregate of particular sets of
dimensions you can do subsetting for
slicing propping and slicing and dicing
there's a bind support arrays or atomic
then there's the table cube in deep fire
which is sort of a structure that hasn't
received very much love or exposure but
it's it's it's relatively a cool idea to
list of arrays and
mimicks my death basically heterogeneous
array records and it has an additional
Lister factor with the mentioned values
it's much more flexible and dim names
that can also have like date date
structures and so on and it has filter
methods in group by stuff but it cannot
for instance deal with simple features
as as dimensions what you would do so
and it doesn't also doesn't have support
regular dimension meaning if I want a
map sort of my space linearly to the
dimension index so what we do in the
Stars packaging starts project is to
implement raster and vector data cubes
and those are MD cubes where one or more
of the dimensions relay to space and
typically one of also to time
so Russell data cubes typically have X&Y
take spatial dimensions effector cubes
have a single dimension that sort of
lists the points lines or polygons that
that acute that the index refers to and
then we have we basically have a list of
arrays and sets of dimensions have
regular dimensions dimensions as values
and take care of measurement units and
coordinate reference systems do the i/o
with T del which we already did with SF
also doing a lot of work with netcdf
which which Michael Sumner is very
instrumental in that side and we support
out of core and we will support cloud
processing and we'll say a little bit
about how that works so you think that
rustic types are easy well they're not
so they're always kind of varieties this
is the nightmare for the developer the
first three sort of had linearly map its
array index to X&Y the last two do not
do that this is like a graticule but it
basically if you have a regular roster
on the earth and you then project it
then it becomes automatically
curvilinear unless you do resampling to
a new regular roster which is what what
the cheetah cubs warping so here's an
image similar to what I showed last year
of what stars does so we read here
little tu TIFF and by but here we use TD
plot and we use a diem stars which is
very primitive which is a tan line
function that essentially decides
should I call diem roster or should I
call the entire depending on what I have
or Jill Jim wrecked it was TM
rusty routine wreck in any case a lot of
other things you still need to do like :
equal and so on and this basically plots
what is their plots the data and that
this that is kind of okay but it sort of
makes it into makes it into you know a
long data frame and then plots all of
the pixels and it is okay up to the
moment that your data are sort of you
know this size that you have like a
typical central to image has 10,000 by
10,000 pixels which means it's a hundred
kilometer by a hundred kilometer area
with ten meter grid cells yes so this is
the state-of-the-art invisible remote
sensing free data of course intelligence
data spy satellites have a much higher
resolution but are not open so if I plot
this thing you think hey it's what is
what's happening here
the thing is basically red here by
saying proxy is true and what happens is
that none of the data is read that only
the metadata is red meaning that only
the dimensions are being read but none
of the image pixels are being touched
and when I plot this data and that's why
I didn't do it with TD plot and sort of
converted into a markdown because that
would sort of take every time ten
minutes before my markdown compiled into
slides if you can't work like that so
this plot method here looks at hey what
is my plot sort of area how many pixels
do I have there or it's much less than
10,000 by 10,000 it's only 800 by 800 so
let's down sample let's only read as
many pixels as if I maximally can view
and then sort of render them and throw
them to the plot device and that is sort
of in a matter of seconds don't compare
to you sort of five or ten minutes and
you can you know continue on this idea
so we have an ST apply here that is
applied to this object which is still
not red and it says to the dimensions X
Y apply this function which is NDVI
which computes a vegetation index by
combining two bands and which is this
little function so it applies this to
every pixel because I have four bands
here it complies it applies it to every
pixel and you think oh this is gonna
take time because it's gonna do this for
this 10,000 cells but no it does nothing
as you see here and only when a plot
this thing
then it does something but then it sort
of it changes execution already so I
have to plot something that means I can
down sample and it down samples and then
it reads only the down sampled a that
computes the NDVI for those and plot
something so this is sort of a query
optimization you could you could say by
by this proxies something that we have
in mind is where the data are basically
not on your local machine but in the
cloud and the next idea is that of the
data cube view where you where you
basically have dimension settings that
you don't read from an image but that
you set independently and we basically
query the imagery on these on this
setting so you could have the in for
instance a collection of images that are
in different projections like you
typically have with sentinel with
satellite or also Landsat data that they
are in over different UTM zones and sort
of handles that an idea that is
pioneered inspired by Google Earth
engine a very strong platform so a lot
of lot of data of course non non cube
data right so we have like space example
events we have spatial networks we have
movement data and there is a nice sort
of data set that is also in the deep
liar available as a subset of this in
the deep liar package called storms for
from his hurricane data set which was
luckily still in the air and it's also
not updated that regularly I think once
per year or something like that this is
a here you see is the color the year of
the of the of the hurricane and the the
path it took without reference only the
that it's long huge and this is
difficult to interpret right so this is
a time series and question is like is
there anything changing over time but
they are all kind of you know it's a
hairy ball so so what to do with it so
you can cut it up and you can say oh
this is nice ggplot and so on and then
but it's still a lot of hairy balls and
you can't really tell there's a lot of a
lot of overlap so you can't really say
is anything increasing or decreasing or
because all the overlap means you don't
know how much there is so what you would
do is really sort of make little boxes
in account in these little boxes and
that's exactly what I did here so I made
little boxes so they made a roster
basically in
two dimensions and then for each of the
roster cells I intersected all of the
lines encountered sort of when there was
a sort of a part of the hurricane going
through the roster cell I counted and I
counted the number of roster cells and
now if you're really smart and you think
hey but this is running from ten degrees
to 80 degrees so what's happening here
is of course they trust our cells if you
would have regular if you would
distribute them regularly over X and y
you get sort of boxes on the earth that
are of completely different size because
they get all the time to get narrower
when you can close to the poles so this
would not sort of work very well but
what I did is said if I made this sort
of this the Y Direction increasing so
they're sort of they're very narrow in
the south and they get sort of taller
when when you get more north so it's
such that we have approximately equal
areas for these for these boxes and that
means it's a rectilinear grid and then
counts are proportional to densities and
you could of course that is ignored
length and duration is strength so you
can do you can do much further much more
with this data but this is a very sort
of simple simple analysis that I start
with so to conclude spatial data science
is an exciting field full with data and
maps challenges and tidy verse
extensions with sf2 simple features
package we extend the tables to spatial
tables and with the starts package we
extend that to raster and vector data
cubes and that includes spatial time
series as a special case stars can do
out of chorister is lazy does some
optimizations there and will eventually
address also cloud raster processing
which is where everything is going in in
this world with in terms of these data
sizes to do something useful we can
analyze big image collections
interactively only when we downsample
cleverly and there is more to read about
sort of the stuff that we do in the book
that I'm writing together with rajab
event a called spatial data science
which is as a link here so the slides
are in a tweet that I sent an hour ago
the link to the slides and also I want
to sort of draw your attention to as a
spatial birds of ever meeting which
takes place tomorrow at breakfast thank
you very much
[Music]
thank you so much Heather and we have
time for a couple of questions
if you can stand up and raise your hand
interoperates you repeat that um the so
SF is for vector spatial teaser and
stars is for aster are they going to
interoperate and something to align the
the coordinate system so yeah this is a
should have put in this whole I should
have put in school with with vector data
cubes so this is the confusion the
confusion is this that starts is about
raster data yes but stars is about
spatial temporal data cubes there are
two types of data cubes raster data
cubes and vector data cubes so if you
have like like this kind of data
geometries with time series then
geometries is one dimension and time is
another one and you could have like
population data per region by age class
for different censuses and you have a 3d
vector data cube right where space take
only one takes only one dimension so it
does both and by that it integrates it
automatically so you could do an
aggregation over your roster and reduce
the to the x and y dimension into a set
of features which could be which could
be polygons thank you a good question no
further questions
[Music]